So, I've worked all over the world and I
constantly get people who think the
housing crisis is just in their country.
People in London think that, people in
New York think that, people in Sydney
think that, people in Melbourne think
that, people in Vancouver think that,
people in LA think that, people in
Mumbai think that, people in Tokyo think
that, people in Shanghai think that.
It's a global problem. And I tell you
right now, you're not going to build
your way out of it. And housing will
become less affordable unless we deal
with the problem of rapidly increasing
wealth of the rich. It's not just
housing, Tom. Look at the stock markets.
Look at the gold price. Look at land
prices. Every single asset class in the
entire world has increased massively in
the last 5 years, in the last 20 years.
This is not a problem of housing. This
is not a problem of London housing. This
is a problem of ordinary people's
inability to compete with a massively
growing wealthy super rich